hello my name is Jennifer and garner and
I am doing the wired autocomplete
interview
[Music]
what Jennifer Garner what was Jennifer
Garner's first movie mr. Magoo for
Disney I don't think it was given a
theatrical release
I played Stacy stampin a ho dietra I
think I was a princess and Leslie
Nielsen was mr. Magoo you can find it
what is Jennifer Garner's real name
Jennifer Garner what sorority is
Jennifer Garner in Pi Beta Phi Ohio is a
chapter 5 beta 5 p i ph apartheid me for
micro beta 5 4 I just love her beta 5
what languages just Jennifer Garner
speak none a little bit of English and
it pay a Tinley I'm time say IAS gay a
nice babe up they not eight really yeah
I did get to really try on a lot of
different languages in alias that was
one of my favorite things and it was
actually one of the hardest things as
well I spoke German a lot on that show
and I really loved that I liked Japanese
cocoa or what - you need cocoa I would
toss cocoa while would touch shoot did
Jennifer Garner go to college yes I did
I went to Denison University in
Granville Ohio and I graduated with in
the BFA in theater performance did
Jennifer Garner do ballet yes I did up
through college and then maybe a little
bit in New York but really mostly junior
high in high school I danced what the
Appalachian youth youth the jazz ballet
under the tutelage of nine elite Denton
did Jennifer Garner do her own stunts
yes I did but I also had a stunt double
and she was my main teacher and coach
and her name's Shawna Duggan's did
Jennifer Garner appear on Law & Order
yes I did but I look totally different
in the episode my roommate in New York
and I had Ovaltine and amaretto every
night after we got home from our
restaurant jobs and we fattened right up
so I look really odd in the episode but
I wasn't it how does Jennifer Garner
stay in shape I did it this morning just
you know it's at like a dance cardio
weights trampoline all kinds of
different things really fun high-energy
super hard but you can do it work out
does Jennifer Garner know karate
well I watch my kids take a lot of
karate classes and I feel like that
should translate does Jennifer Garner
have pierced ears no
I don't my dad didn't think growing up
girls should have pierced ears
what color is Jennifer Garner's eyes
they're brown but I've been wishing them
into hazel because I want green eyes so
I feel like they're turning more hazel
what personality type is Jennifer Garner
I'm an introvert and an extrovert I'm an
extroverted inter right or an
introverted extroverted I don't know
what a wonderful question if Google has
an answer Google do you have an answer
for me Who am I what is Jennifer
Garner's diet I actually have an answer
to this I've been following be well by
Kelly because I was getting ready for a
movie where I had to look a certain way
I actually really liked the diet so I've
stuck on it is Jennifer Garner the pink
Power Ranger um
no shoot I wish I were at the pink Power
Ranger but actually I think it was Amy
Joe Johnson if I remember correctly is
Jennifer Garner James corners
granddaughter that's sweet that they
would say granddaughter no but I used to
tell people in the marching band growing
up that he was my uncle and when we
graduated from high school the tuba
player John said to me is your uncle
James coming to graduation and I do
happen to have an uncle Jim and so I
said no why would he and he was like I
just thought I'd get to meet a famous
guy and then I had to admit I've been
lying to you since seventh grade
it is Jennifer Garner in a pampers
commercial as the baby or as the mom no
I'm not it's Jennifer Garner I get
Canadian I'm gonna take this is the
hugest compliment cuz that must mean I'm
nice no I'm not Canadian
no no but I'm but my my father Victor
Garber is is Jennifer Garner vegan no
I'm sorry
don't tell my furry friends it's never
occurred to me to Google things about
myself before but now I'm gonna see what
Google has to say about my personality
type actually I'm not I'm too scared
I'm not going to is Jennifer Garner's
kids school calling to say that somebody
is sick nope